hello citizens of the reject nation greg
and john i'm i think that's who you are
john of house humphrey we are going to watch
the comic-con trailer that we are obviously
very late to watching house of the dragon
we haven't seen any of the trailers for how
the dragon is it'll be fresh but we did you know
cover the last couple seasons of game of thrones
right here on the channel so if you guys want
to watch those reactions you can have already
visited game of thrones since last watching it
but i am very curious mainly because matt smith
is in this series and i i am hearing that a lot
of people are being very receptive to everything
they're seeing and so we were like maybe we
should cover it and i'm like well if we're
planning on covering it why don't we at least
check out a trailer first and see how we respond
to the trailer so with that in mind leave a like
that wouldn't take too much of your time so please
just go out of your way to move those opposable
thumbs and boom let's swing action people
the dream was clearer than a memory and
i heard the sound of a thundering hooves
splintering shields and ringing swords
and i placed my hair up on the iron throne
i consider the matter urgent that of your
succession reciprocity is the most dangerous seat
in the realm and our line is vulnerable too easily
ended who else would have a claim the firstborn
child wow that's horrible has ever sat the
iron front the king has an heir damon targaryen
no queen has set the iron throne
between my brother and my daughter
knives will come out you are the king
your first duty is to pick a new wife
nice
conflict do you think the realm will ever
accept me as that queen the lords of the
realm bent the knee a woman would not inherit the
iron throne because that is the order of things
for
your now has dragons
there are power men should
never have tried for cliff
whoa more dragon action like smaug
she will block my way our hearts
remain as one our hearts will never won
you never imagined yourself on the iron throne
where he sacrificed
holy [__] that looks great wow that looks really
good yeah that was a good trailer it was a great
trailer it's a great i didn't think i'd be all
right i'm not gonna lie to you guys i did not
think i'd be excited for this show that's the
reason i've been avoiding it and haven't really
been like on yeah yeah there's some good will
to build back after the end of game of thrones
i loved game of thrones and i still feel like
you know even with the final season there was
so much to still appreciate about what they did
however after it was done i was like okay i'm
i'm i'm i'm ready to say bye yeah even though
i still think it's one of the best despite its
last season i still think it's one of the best
shows ever made but then to come back to here
like this looks pretty awesome it does look good
it looks great yeah one a it looks really really
tangible and that's the thing is like game of
thrones like upped the ante in terms of just
how far we are going to go to get these crazy
locations and these incredible just that moment
where you're like staring through like racks
of candles and everything like you really feel
like you are in a whole other time and place and
then to go back this is based on source material
and for me that's been my biggest thing is like
what we've learned from game of thrones is that
it's a bit of a slippery slope when you're
off-roading past the source material but
this does have a book to draw from that gets me
excited for the whole thing because it looks great
and now i'm confident in what they have based it
off of and i love the look of the cast too like
well i mean i don't remember everyone's name
here but it seems like a really funny thing
i heard targaryen at one point you know
it's pretty obvious that you got a pretty
simple plot like i like that the not the
plot is simple i'm sure there's a lot of
complexities and politics and dealing with legacy
all these things involved with you know the world
of house of the dragon but the plot is so focused
on the fight for the iron throne and mainly
focusing on the two targaryens the brother of the
king and the daughter of the king and watching
as that comes in the conflict and i like that
conflict because they are related they are blood
and they are fighting for the spot and it has two
completely different meanings for each one of them
you know and then i like how that is a central
focus plot so it was easy to latch on to where
you know like that is a aspect to game of thrones
uh that is a definitely an a main ingredient to
the show but it didn't start off as this is the
central focus of the fight for the iron throne
yeah right away and i like that they're they're
grounding it in that and you're gonna explore the
history and i think this will even help serve the
daenerys storyline down the road because there's
so much talk in this trailer you know with the
targaryens they're going to be a woman in there
rather see the city burn you know yeah it's never
going to happen yeah it looks like they could
definitely do some some rhyming you know it's
like poetry uh they could do some rhyming yeah
definitely as a mechas dude yeah sorry they could
do some of that and they could also like there's
so much made out of you know the legacy of the
targaryens even in what we saw in game of thrones
and you know the history of dragons and all that
so this does feel like a very natural place to
go that yeah we'll have you know in impact not
impact but it will be informed by what we've seen
in game of thrones and it will you know sort of
tie in in what feels like a very natural way to
that yeah yeah i was impressed i was impressed
it looks a little more fantastical just because
of the fact that you're dealing with dragons much
more prevalent like the dragons didn't even come
in to play until like a few seasons into game of
thrones that was a big part of game of thrones
was the rebirth of the dragon again and here
it still actually feels much more war heavy
and a little bit more it's like all these things
i'm saying i'm like no game of thrones did do that
but there is like you said the word tangible and
so it does feel a little bit more real world yet
has more of the fantasy of the dragons yeah so it
is kind of interesting it it does feel more like
not exactly scuzzy but a little bit more gritty
and you know yeah you're in an earlier time where
it's like you know you're already that's more of
a medieval it's already yeah a medieval sort of
dirty world that game of thrones occupies so this
being even earlier than that has to be that much
grimier and that much more primitive in certain
ways at least yeah yeah like a harsh world to
live in so we'll see we'll see i hope it delivers
i hope it lands and um yeah what do you guys think
are you excited for the show should we cover it
comes out in a few weeks regardless now i'm at
a point where i'm like well i'm definitely gonna
watch it again even if we don't react to it i'm
definitely gonna watch it so yeah subscribe
leave a like and hey let's answer the page
ricardo of house martinez there are no latinos
in the game of thrones universe i feel like
you should be the first latino knight to
write in they're like what was pedro pascal
pedro pascal was a martell and they were from
you know there are hispanics in the game of
thrones universe i just uh you know there are
no not enough not enough man especially in this
part of the universe where it's like everyone's
blondes your blonde hair like stuff like we need
you to come bring some flavor to the iron
throat chile yeah turn the iron throne into
an iron skillet you know throw some chili powder
on there you know make up some carne asada or
something this is getting dangerously close to
being a racist child that's like your last chat
that's right man that's all we do here is just
dance on the phone but uh hey buddy love you
hope you're doing well thanks for sticking with
us and hey if you're a game of thrones fan let
us know and then uh maybe we'll shout you out
when the show's actually on rock on rock on
you